no
[Música]
si le preguntara a todas las mujeres del
mundo sin importar el país en el que
viven ni el idioma que hablan qué es lo
que piensan cada vez que se paran frente
a sus clósets
seguramente casi todas contestarían no
tengo nada que ponerme y digo casi todas
porque para validar lo obvio en enero
del 2020
hicimos una encuesta a más de 1000
mujeres y ratificamos que 86 por ciento
de ellas piensan que no tienen nada que
ponerse aún cuando sus armarios están
llenos de ropa pero porque están los
armarios llenos de ropa que no usamos
les voy a contar una historia tengo 14
años trabajando en la industria de la
moda y durante mucho tiempo tuve acceso
a una especie de closet infinito e
inconsciente cuando abría mi armario me
sorprendía al ver prendas que no
recordaba haber usado
muchas conservaban incluso las etiquetas
mi closet era prácticamente un espacio
de acumulación de ropa que jamás
volvería a usar y un ejemplo perfecto de
derroche de dinero tener ropa nueva en
una especie de ilusión que se esfumaba
una vez que la estrenaba o incluso sin
haber mala puesto tenía demasiados
vestidos y de estos al menos la mitad
jamás fue usada tan siquiera una vez me
quedé con muchas prendas solo para
tomarme fotos ese día supe que yo
también compartía el dilema de casi
todas las mujeres del mundo era un hecho
que no repetía la ropa una vez que la
publicaba en mis redes sociales y es que
al igual que a casi todas me daba
vergüenza que la gente me viera usar lo
mismo en varias oportunidades porque hoy
las personas consideran las
publicaciones de estas fotografías
un evento en sí mismo
gracias a las redes sociales una de cada
dos mujeres no quiere ser vista con la
misma ropa más de dos veces y esto se
agrava cuando hablamos de vestidos aún
cuando sabemos que no volveremos a usar
esas prendas si tienen algún valor
económico o sentimental importante para
nosotros irónicamente podríamos
guardarlas por años en el armario siendo
ésta una de las maneras más absurdas de
conservar un activo y ha depreciado
tanta ropa consumimos que por una parte
cada segundo un camión de textiles es
tirado a los vertederos de basura y por
la otra sólo en eeuu anualmente se
cuelan en los closets más de 9 mil
millones de prendas de vestir que
representan más de 500 billones de
dólares
la buena noticia es que desde ese día
jamás volví a comprar tanta ropa y me
hizo muy feliz saber que él igual que yo
el mundo estaba cambiando hoy la
existencia de 74 millones de usuarios
sólo en eeuu dispuestos a utilizar
plataformas de ropa de segunda mano nos
dice que los consumidores han estado
buscando soluciones para esa ropa que
cuelga casi nueva en sus closets y que
nunca más usarán de estos 74 millones
casi la mitad comenzó a consumir ropa de
segunda mano durante el 2020 en parte
debido a la concientización del consumo
producto de la pandemia del cobi 19 se
proyecta que en sólo 9 años el mercado
de la ropa de segunda mano doble al
mercado de la moda rápida no obstante
estas impresionantes cifras las
soluciones actualmente disponibles para
nosotros como usuarios
presentan aún grandes desafíos
conscientes de que la industria de la
moda es la segunda más contaminante del
planeta o bien para obtener algo de
dinero millones de usuarios entre los
que me incluyo
hemos recurrido a plataformas de reventa
de ropa de segunda mano sin embargo el
problema de estas plataformas está en lo
que recuperas
considerando que la ropa se deprecia
casi por completo al momento de salir de
la tienda en el mejor de los casos
obtendrás solo hasta un 30% del monto
invertido en la misma si es cierto que
te van a dar dinero por ella pero
resulta frustrante que lo que recibas
generalmente es muy inferior al precio
final de venta de esa misma prenda en
las plataformas de segunda mano por lo
que deberás vender hasta tres piezas de
similar valor si quisieras volver a
comprar tu misma prenda en el sitio
donde la ven diste y aquí te voy a dar
un ejemplo de la vida real un día decidí
vender en una de estas plataformas el
vestido que usé para la boda de mi
hermano llevaba 15 años deslumbrando al
público con este despampanante traje y
entendí que ya era hora de dejarlo ir lo
vendo en este sitio recibo mi dinero y
que creen
me encuentro en esta página un vestido
igual pero de otro color ya yo sabía que
era un modelo ganador entonces si
cambiaba el color podría seguir
deslumbrando por algún tiempo más pero
mi alegría
desapareció cuando me di cuenta que
debía pagar el triple de lo que había
recibido por mi vestido que lo único que
tenía diferente era el color otros
usuarios por el contrario han optado por
rentar trajes por ocasiones especiales
ya que es un hecho que este tipo de ropa
se usa en promedio solo hasta tres veces
resulta ilógico gastar cientos de
dólares en una prenda de vestir que
usarás solo en una oportunidad en vez de
rentar la por una pequeña fracción del
costo de compra sin duda la renta se ha
convertido hoy en una de las maneras más
populares de ahorrar dinero en materia
de vestuario pero aquí existen dos
problemas en primer lugar rentar prendas
de vestir aún tiene un gran impacto
ambiental las piezas rentadas se
despachan y regresan decenas de veces
antes de ser desechadas pero si bien es
cierto que reducimos las emisiones de
carbono al no comprar una prenda nueva
te pregunto cuántas emisiones se
producen en el transporte de las prendas
que se envían y retornan una y otra vez
y en segundo lugar el proceso de lavado
pocas veces es tan amigable con el
ambiente como la gente piensa ya que el
reuso intensivo de una prenda
generalmente supone el uso de demasiados
productos químicos tóxicos para poder
ser higienizadas ahora bien
sin rentas evitas comprar pero qué pasa
con esas prendas que siguen colgando en
tu closet siempre había pensado que la
mejor solución para renovar las prendas
era el intercambio imagínense poder
cambiar lo que tenemos en nuestro closet
por otras prendas de similar calidad y
valor pero hay un problema y es que para
que el intercambio de prendas entre
personas funcione a una escala global a
todo el mundo le debería gustar la ropa
de los demás y para hacerlo más difícil
que darle es por eso que aunque
intercambiar ropa es la manera más justa
de renovar tu armario es también la
manera más ineficiente de hacerlo
con esto en la cabeza estudie por algún
tiempo
plataformas de intercambio de ropa donde
los usuarios subían sus prendas y debían
esperar que a otro usuario le gustará su
ropa y viceversa este proceso podría
tomar meses me di cuenta de problemas
adicionales como que no se podía
realmente verificar que la ropa que se
transaba estuviera en las condiciones
que describían sus dueños y peor aún
era casi imposible evitar estafas como
se le podía comprometer a los
participantes a efectivamente enviar las
prendas al otro una vez que recibían las
de ellos
definitivamente un proceso inseguro y
absolutamente ineficiente que evitaba
que el único método realmente ecuánime
para renovar ropa usada pudiera escalar
se de un momento a otro me obsesione por
encontrar una solución para dar una
segunda vida a toda esa ropa que casi
sin uso va prácticamente de la tienda al
basurero y entonces me pregunte cuál era
la pieza que faltaba en este
rompecabezas
cómo podía crear una plataforma de
intercambio que realmente funcionara el
éxito de las empresas que hoy escalan
rápidamente radica en ciertos atributos
que les permiten generar un impacto diez
veces mayor que otras empresas de su
industria a una velocidad récord con
menos inversión estas empresas que
crecen en un ritmo vertiginoso son las
llamadas organizaciones
exponenciales si quería hacer del
intercambio de ropa de segunda mano una
industria eficiente y escalable debía
apoyarme en un atributo que usado de una
manera muy particular nos permitiría
romper las transacciones 11 e
intercambiar la mayor cantidad de
prendas de manera ilimitada los llamados
activos apalancados y es que con la ropa
de terceros alimentaremos nuestro propio
inventario lo que nos permitiría
convertirnos en la mayor plataforma de
intercambio de ropa usada sin necesidad
de pagar millones de dólares en un
inventario propio ni esperar por un
segundo usuario para ejecutar las
transacciones la abundancia de estos
activos fácilmente disponibles
constituiría la clave para hacer la
diferencia y así el 4 de julio del 2019
se me ocurrió pues
tenía frente a mí una idea que podía
cambiar de muchas maneras del mundo y en
ese momento solo yo era la dueña pero al
principio ni siquiera yo creía que esto
fuera posible cuando le contaba sobre el
regreso a las personas la mayoría me
tomaba por loca empezando por mi esposo
quien me acusó de querer cambiar el
mundo en vez de montar un spa con la
cantidad de mujeres que tú conoces
roxana nunca se me va a olvidar
nadie veía cómo podía yo sin recursos ni
contactos ejecutar un proyecto tan
ambicioso pero yo sabía que había
encontrado una solución que mejoraría la
vida de millones de personas y entonces
utilicé mi cuenta de instagram para
intentar un experimento colgué todos mis
vestidos en la sala de mi casa e invite
a seis mujeres a hacer un intercambio de
ropa el resultado fue el siguiente en
promedio intercambiaron 9 vestidos cada
una el ahorro aproximado en este pequeño
intercambio fue de 5 mil 600 dólares con
estos datos y sin que nadie creyera en
mi visión comencé por estudiar un
diplomado de emprendimiento patrocinado
por la universidad de wharton allí
comenzó la búsqueda de toda la
información que mi cabeza pudiera
procesar luego hice un pequeño plan de
negocios y una presentación y con eso
apliqué a uno de los programas de
emprendimiento de la universidad de
harvard y a la semana recibí la
aceptación para mí significó mucho
porque en ese momento yo era una mujer
que de nuevo estaba persiguiendo un
sueño
con esa misma convicción me inscribí
para formar parte de founder institute
la aceleradora de negocios más grande
del mundo y el día en que fue aceptada
decidí tomar el programa con la
determinación de convertir a ruiz west
en nada menos que el próximo unicornio
de la moda el programa comenzó el 7 de
abril del 2020 y desde ese día estudio
en promedio de 80 horas a la semana
durante los siguientes cuatro meses
también estudiaba inglés en paralelo y
para la misma época logré obtener una
certificación como innovadora
exponencial otorgada por la organización
española propuso la ians
todos los martes debía defender a reyes
frente a sofisticados mentores no les
miento si les digo que me sentía en un
reality show si el modelo de negocios
era inconsistente el emprendedor era
eliminado el programa de manera
inmediata entonces todos los martes
vivía mi infierno personal porque al
menos una hora antes de cada
presentación
vomitaba perdía la voz sudaba frío
respiraba con dificultad y me llenaba de
angustia porque el fantasma del no puedo
se hacía presente semana tras semana sin
excepción sin embargo comenzaron 23
startups y entre las pocas que
culminamos widgets se llevó el tercer
lugar un logro gigante en un programa
donde sólo habíamos dos mujeres y yo era
la latina que batallaba con el inglés
con el acento al estilo de sofía vergara
así regrese luego de graduarse se
convirtió en la primera startup del
grupo en levantar su primera ronda de
capital fue a partir de ese momento
cuando comenzamos a trabajar
intensamente en la construcción de
nuestra versión beta la invitación a
regrese a formar parte del milan fashion
tech nuestra participación en el
programa create del miami dade college
los campamentos de fans andrés startups
a los que hemos sido invitados y una
certificación internacional como
conferencista solo por si alguna vez te
han invitado a dar esta charla son
pequeños logros que me animan a seguir
adelante en este camino que me ha tocado
transitar para cumplir el sueño de mi
vida cambiar el mundo un vestido a la
vez malcolm gladwell dice que
necesitamos 10.000 horas de práctica
deliberada para alcanzar la maestría y
el éxito en un campo determinado
hoy luego de 120 semanas y trabajando un
promedio de 50 horas a la semana he
logrado acumular alrededor de 6000
mucha gente pensaba que falta mucho pero
yo solo pienso a poco más de la mitad
del camino que nunca había llegado tan
lejos y que tengo toda la fuerza
suficiente para completar las horas que
hagan falta he de confesarles que hay
días en los que me cuesta más agregar
horas pero para mí el secreto del éxito
no es la motivación sino nuestro
compromiso por lograr nuestros sueños
cuando no estamos motivados hoy es una
realidad la versión beta del primer
sitio escalable de intercambio de ropa
de vestir en los eeuu un sitio en el que
las personas podrán renovar sus closets
usando sus propias prendas como moneda
un mercado digital donde quien oferta y
quien demanda es la misma persona
una plataforma que permite intercambios
inmediatos gracias a un inventario
propio alimentado por las piezas de sus
mismos usuarios un lugar donde todo lo
que recibimos es verificado por nuestro
equipo permitiendo a nuestra comunidad
obtener piezas certificadas y de similar
valor a la que están entregando widgets
es un emprendimiento social que nos
permitirá ahorrar hasta 90% de lo que
gastaríamos comprando ropa al tiempo que
evitamos que prendas casi nuevas formen
parte de las 800 mil toneladas de basura
textil que todos los años llegan a los
vertederos una idea que puede cambiar la
manera en la que el mundo entero consume
ropa el intercambio es un sistema libre
de prejuicios sustentables
económicamente responsable y lleno de
equidad un estilo de vida que nos
permitirá por cada millón de piezas
intercambiadas reducir 11 mil toneladas
de dióxido de carbono
ahorrar más de 80 millones de dólares
cuando intercambias tus prendas jamás
volverás a hacer el mismo el mundo
necesita de personas que estén
dispuestas a convertir ideas increíbles
en realidad
necesita de personas que persiguen un
propósito de transformación masiva para
inspirar a otros y transformar al mundo
personas que comiencen por cambiar sus
propias vidas para educar con el ejemplo
personas que entiendan que el futuro
pertenece a los que no se conforman con
el presente
personas que no hayan venido a jugar el
juego sino a cambiarlo hoy te invito a
ser una de ellas mi nombre es roxana
ceccato y soy la creadora de richter es
la primera plataforma de intercambio de
ropa escalable en los eeuu muchas
gracias